what's going on reject nation ah shoot
it's a Marvel trailer and I'm wearing a
Batman shirt again oh how could you what
are you doing man you're not allowed to
like two things at once nuances don't
exist there's not a sliding scale of
taste in this world you got to pick one
and stick to it don't change your mind
don't be a flip-flopper don't accrue new
information and factor it into the way
that you think just like one thing
homogenized your taste then nothing's a
mystery and everything is a surprise
because nothing is a surprise you got a
shirt oh you got three shirts hey hey
big spender
proving just how much of a Marvel fan
you are yeah this is like that scene in
every superhero movie we're like the
comedy guy takes his shirt off yeah
except I don't have a Marvel oh are you
gonna put that one on me look at me I'm
a huge Marvel fan let's watch the
official trailer for the runaway Gregg
Sulkin
[Music]
I miss you
I hope you're right about this not being
a big deal that's what the parents do
Cole changes
why is my mom's first year
how did he know to turn that such a
stack of coasters oh no oh they watch it
might kill someone
[Music]
I have so many questions no matter what
we are we can't let our parents keep
getting away with this stuff
[Music]
Oh spike
[Music]
I've chills you have to stop this no one
else will
what
[Music]
dang
[Music]
cool interesting all right I didn't
realize that James Marsters was in this
from Buffy it's funny because it kind of
has a little bit of a Buffy vibe yeah I
was thinking that I was thinking that
partway through who's involved with the
leg - who's the showrunner here is it
one of their because they're people
Drechsel okay well done man doing
everything on the show shooting this
show right in the show directing every
episode of the show starring in the show
playing most of the lead cast you're
really great chameleon I'm a dude man
this cast is diverse I saw white I saw
black I saw an Asian that's all that
matters right now is that diversity
train brother I mean the diversity train
is a good train to be on regardless yeah
the damage I'm just saying I'm st. good
on Hulu it kind of reminds me a little
bit more this might have said some
people if I say this but it kind of
reminds me a little bit more of the CW
shows like the arrowverse kind of has a
little more of that cheesy you
light-hearted but at the same time with
a mixture of that Marvel darkness from
television that I've sort of come to
expect it seems to be having finally
this sort of blend I think I've taken
advantage of that because they're
they're putting it on a new television
program because Netflix is like their
really dark over there and then here
they could kind of have this hybrid
where it's more for a teen audience yeah
the way I feel like the flash and arrow
are I feel like that shows can be for
adults but I feel at the end of the day
it's more for for teens and that's kind
of the vibe I get here well yeah it's
not it doesn't look actively as gritty
and as you know bone breaking is yeah
the Netflix Marvel shows can be and
that's that's why I think the Buffy
parallel made sense because Buffy had
those equal levels of like huge stakes
you know supernatural situation that we
gotta stop but also you know an ensemble
with a lot of humor and you know yeah
relatable more youthful issues and stuff
what I really like about the trailer is
how weird everything gets you know I
wasn't sure if these kids are gonna be
something The Runaways would be these
these children who seem to really be
in control of their gifts and abilities
but it seems like they're all kind of
new yeah and growing into them yeah they
should make sense since they're
teenagers so it feels like they're all
growing into and truly knowing how to
hone in on their powers and strengths
that sometimes they seem like they're a
little surprised by what they can do
yeah but I also love the weirdness of it
you see some weird creatures in there
you got some human sacrifice going on a
lot of different types of powers and
abilities I appreciate seeing this comic
book show kind of go all out with that
vibe it's like a great show on CW I
called Riverdale which has nothing to do
with Marvel and DC right Archie Archie
comics are she's not DC heard she is is
just its own thing right so you don't
understand that show it has like murder
and mystery and it's a high school show
I feel like this sort of it's not really
about murder mystery going on in high
school but it's with high schoolers
going up against their parents who are
worst enemies in real life I've found a
weird pattern in movies now where I'm
always suspicious of when like kids
whose parents all hang out together also
all hang out together like there's some
kind of vacuum scenario going on there
and it turns out that that's true our
parents hung out together all the times
right they did remember that one time we
tried making a Tekken short for Mom got
really upset at my dad cause I took us
to the wrong Park for two hours and had
everyone waiting yeah that's them
hanging out that's what that's really
like I'm with you on that on the the
tone of this and stuff and I feel like
this is a nice opportunity to rebrand
that more you know network esque
Tambor Oh show yeah I think as agents of
shield I've seen a few episodes of and
it never really grabbed me and you know
the inhuman what's it what's a new show
in humans it doesn't seem like anybody's
been really big on that and so I feel
like I did the Ranger through the roof
um through the ceiling the stratosphere
got picked up for like three more
seasons oh did they cuz I would believe
you I feel like this is a nice
opportunity to rebrand you know a
different caliber of Marvel show because
Hulu does a lot of the network stuff
they they bring over for streaming a lot
of that stuff and I think that for them
to cut in with original Marvel show this
could be really cool my question is why
are they sacrificing young girls I mean
I do that on my own but why are they
doing it yeah well you know I think you
should first examine why you do it and
see if there's anything that you we
don't may go into that all right I've
been therapy for four years I'll get
there eventually my theory is they're
trying to unlock some type of godlike
power obviously because she was going
off oh yeah crystal skull on us there I
feel like that's the only reason people
really ever do these kind of sacrifice
things you know to gain favor of or or
you know open the door to channeling
some almighty power yeah that's gonna
you know Mabley think they're doing
something good maybe that'll be maybe
there'll be some moral conflict here
where there's a great or good but you
know it's not really a greater good cuz
you know bad things have to happen in
order to achieve it yeah yeah yeah kudos
on the Velociraptor being in there
that's a hard thing to promote in a
random trailer like this
cooter philosoraptor being in here
clever girl
clever girl I just want throw out there
one more time super eggs you look great
you are one hunky dunky beautiful man
with an American accent that sounds way
better than my voice keep it up keep it
up J hope this show is a success rootin
for you and thanks for already inviting
me to all the premiere and rap parties
thanks yeah from me I have forged
messages I know you and I really really
appreciate it subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media and also
we have a patreon go check it out a lot
of fun stuff being posted on there as of
late we're also on a pretty rad app
called Stardust come on over there quick
three to 30-second reactions for movies
TV shows trailers anything come follow
us post drone all that junk we're gonna
get undressed now
now we're ready to being a Marvel shoe